vou botar rafael dia 17 é pra mostrar
como eu acho que o mundo pode mudar vou
mostrar como pessoas mudaram meu mundo
fizeram de um dia diferente a 0 dava
melhor pra mim com isso os jogos que
como eu sinto na obrigação de fazer
parte da sociedade
na entrevista uma vez mais sozinho e sem
haver consenso da comunidade da
sociedade
uma pessoa foi uma pessoa que ninguém
aqui sozinho
todo mundo tá ligado a uma rede a um
grupo de jornalistas jornalistas
há uns anos seguintes à segunda feira 1º
com um chute de henrique cardoso como
presidente de 80 anos conduzir ao meia
em entrevista com ele foi uma aposta do
presidente da academia paulista de
letras
também falando com ele e várias outras
coisas que eu imaginava que fosse fazer
com 13 anos
acho que o legal da foco é que cada um é
diferente
expressam bem na frente da câmera
anunciou tem uma desenvoltura melhor
alguns escrevem muito bem e um pouco de
cada um acaba contribuindo pra cá fora
posto especial pra mim e ela me mostrou
porque não podia não precisava só ir à
escola e voltar pra casa depois da
escola de novo objeto de outras coisas
que eu podia aumentar o meu mundo de uma
adolescente de 13 anos
a gente fazia todas as etapas da matéria
que a gente ajudava na filmagem e edição
na divulgação e acho que toda essa
desenvolvimento e todo esse acabar com
aquela relação professor aluno de
distância e todo mundo trabalhando junto
foi o que fez a falta de um melhor e ela
fez procurar outras coisas como eu falei
e ele aos 15 16 anos eu comecei no
voluntariado que eu vou falar
eu faço parte do senhor acordado uma ong
foi fundada no méxico 1998 pelo davi
pela frente são dois jovens que
acreditavam que nem todo mundo num que o
jovem não só que é mas ele pode sim
mudar um mudar o mundo através do que na
formação de valores
a gente acredita todos os projetos
acreditam que a gente tem que trabalhar
com crianças não só carentes de amor de
afeta mas também de valores
a gente quer formar não só futuros
adultos mas sim futuros cidadãos que com
dignidade com honestidade com respeito
são valores era acordar chegar lá e faz
parte do projeto mente para sempre
será que é uma foto de um dos eventos
que a gente fez e como eu falei
a gente trabalha com crianças de
instituições carentes aqui em são paulo
a nossa nosso projeto trabalha com a
inscrição do de taboão da serra e nossos
encontros com as crianças são uma vez
por mês
como falei a ong é de jovens projovem
nada mais justo do que os próprios
jovens participarem de toda a
organização do evento não tem alguém que
vai preparar tudo pra gente a gente
chega lá e só partido
os nossos voluntários vão atrás passam
semanas ligando indo atrás é hoje
as crianças como é que vai ser a
alimentação do evento como essa
atividade
a gente faz reunião com a gente grande e
quando chega o dia do evento
a gente vê toda aquela aquela animação
de todo mundo que passou umas três
semanas lá atrás e também animado para
começar o dia
é muito legal de ver todo mundo lá junto
pra fazer o dia de uma criança
no primeiro semestre agora a gente
negócio crianças no corpo de bombeiros
uma vez pra ver como funcional tinha
nele se lembra que no meio do dia teve
uma ocorrência tocou a sirene e os
números saíram no meio dia e às crianças
para um mega armadas e são todas as
experiências que elas estão vivendo pela
primeira vez nos leva a uma escola de
circo também neste semestre o aluno
muitas pela primeira vez no teatro são
todas as experiências que nós jovens de
15 e 16 anos estão proporcionando às
crianças
a última foto e outra vez que a gente
fez nesse evento a gente a alimentação
dele funcionava tipo o samba sabe pegar
um pão com recheio depois colocava num
saquinho então uma outra falta do evento
e um outro projeto que eu gosto bastante
também dentro do senhor é o superasse a
definição básica dele é sint causar uma
mudança física no lugar de
vulnerabilidade social mas sim
depois de cinco minutos de inspiração a
gente percebe que é muito mais difícil
só o fato de aqueles jovens saírem de
casa no feriado de três dias quatro irem
para uma comunidade carente para almoçar
com aquelas pessoas para passar o dia
com ela para conversar com elas entendem
delas vai muito mais do que só pintar um
asilo ou só pintar
não que isso seja pouco mas é muito mais
do que isso eu fui superação agora na
páscoa durou três dias
caçapava no quintal asilo e sentido de
caçapa
quando eu voltei do domingo e foi direto
para a casa da minha avó para o almoço
de páscoa na mochila tinha uma luva de
pintura um óculos de pintura
ela estava toda suja de tinta e eu
cheguei sempre no meio da mesa e comecei
a mostrar para todo mundo as fotos do
meu feriado e tudo que tinha vivido toda
a experiência nova tinha passado e
lembra que a minha tia falou algo do
tipo mas calma agora foi feriado que
esses jovens se mostrou as fotos estavam
na praia tão curtinho bom mas podia ter
na praia mas eu acho que a gente não
tava não só porque era a coisa certa
para fazer é mais além disso porque era
divertida era bem divertido foi bem
objetivo
o remo é o diretor do centro acordado
aqui de são paulo
ele falou uma coisa que eu acho que
ilustra bem o que é o propósito deste
projecto
ele falou nessa operação a gente podia
muito bem ter contratado empresa o
possui uma doação do trabalho teria sido
sair até mais barato e até melhor mas a
gente não fez a diferença que a gente
faz na vida das pessoas
passamos dias com ela vai muito além do
acordado tenho vários projetos que são
as fotos deles é uma festa que organizou
agora em junho o chamado dia de sonho a
mais ou menos 4 mil voluntários num
domingo será acordado hoje ele tem mais
ou menos 450 voluntários só que em são
paulo desde que ele entrou no brasil
2000 e já atendeu mais ou menos 15 mil
pessoas
são todos jovens voluntários são todos
jovens
o pessoal mais velho que eu conheça um
tem mais ou menos uns 30 anos
agora imagine se alguém tivesse chegado
por davi próprio atrás tinha falado que
eles eram muito jovens para fazer alguma
coisa talvez a senhora quando existir
bom
outro grupo que vou falar eu fui
apresentar um projeto em estudo cultural
orientada a sair e é um fórum para
discutir idéias tipo que a gente está
fazendo aqui na educação do país
lembro que quando eu estava no ônibus eu
fiquei pensando ah vai ser divertido
assim
se eles pensarem que um grupo de jovens
saindo apresentar um trabalho que jovens
estão envolvidos e engajados no
voluntariado
quando cheguei lá e vi que tinha uma
sala só destinado para o voluntariado e
comecei a conversar com os grupos
eu percebi que não não era só gente
todos os outros lá eram jovens e estavam
mega envolvidos no trabalho deles e que
eles estavam fazendo
a gente via quando apresentavam quando
eles sabiam de tudo aquilo quando eles
tinham vivido tudo aquilo que eles
gostaram daquilo lá eu vi o que pra mim
é voluntariado
acho que a gente tem que dirigir ficar
toda essa história de voluntariado
voluntário é aquela pessoa santa que não
saem e se diverte
eu saio me divirto eu faço besteira mas
eu acho que o que diferencia o
voluntário de uma outra pessoa é que ele
escolheu e além
ele escolheu dar um passo à frente ele
sabe que o governo sim tem que lidar com
as políticas públicas e tem que cuidar
da população mas que todos nós fazemos
empate da sociedade civil e cabe a nós
fazer uma coisa voluntário jovem ele
sabe que ele mora em são paulo uma
cidade que a cada 12 pessoas
uma delas é analfabeta ele mora no
brasil um país que 3,6 milhões de jovens
de 14 a 17 anos na escola
acho que além de tudo desde que entrei
no voluntariado e desenvolver
habilidades e nem que nem sabia que
existiam habilidade de falar em público
habilidade de liderança habilidade de
lidar com alguns entrevistas quando
chegava na sexta feira e tinha uma coisa
pra fazer novo sonhar acordado a gente
grava noite fazendo a gente e até o
último minuto para tudo dar certo
são coisas que se não tivesse entrado eu
tenho certeza que não teria feito
acho que a gente pode sim fazer uma
coisa
hoje o brasil é o nono país em número de
voluntários
desses 67% ou seja dois terços trabalho
em tempo integral ou seja eles não
deixaram de fazer nada sem deixar de ter
uma carreira pra fazer voluntário
vivi uma vida normal e não privaria as
necessidades pessoais deles um projeto a
pessoa
acho que aquela ideia já tinha falado no
começo do nelson mandela do mundo
não é uma coisa tão teórica mas uma
coisa prática a gente tá assim ligado
todo mundo eu tô ligado com jogos o
acordado
estou ligado nos jogos de cox e porque a
gente não pode ligar pra mim quando eu
fui caçapava no feriado
na missa do domingo o diretor do lado do
brasil da instituição falou pra gente
que a gente não tinha idéia da diferença
que a gente tinha feito na vida daqueles
senhores só tem lá um deles não tinha
nem dormindo na noite anterior porque
sabia que a gente ia chegar
estava conversando com meu pai do dia e
ele falou de uma metáfora que 99 tem a
ver com o fato de alguns peixes como o
peixe dourado ea capa eles crescerem
dependendo do tamanho do aquário que
eles estão
ou seja ele só não foi menor eles
crescem pouco maior
eles querem mais gente a pensar nisso
nós traçamos objetivos na hora de
escrever que a gente queria fazer antes
de morrer longe do vídeo tem dia hora de
a gente respirar outra pessoa
uma outra onda que são paulo a liga
solidária falou uma coisa que eu acho
bem perto da definição deles voluntário
é aquele que do seu trabalho o seu tempo
e talento
achei muito certo acho que antes de a
gente se conhecer um grupo de pessoas
que está disposto a dar muito dinheiro
para um grupo de crianças carentes
a gente se perguntar se as pessoas tão
dispostas a passar o dia com uma criança
uma das crianças eu acho que as pessoas
que eu conheci os jovens que estou
falando para vocês lista estão
envolvidos nisso e isso que mudou o
mundo e estou tentando passar pra você